maintenant une autre pierre dans le
parcours du centre hospitalier
universitaire de montréal le chum c'est
un projet de centre hospitalier
gigantesque qui va regrouper trois
hôpitaux de montréal et dont les travaux
sont en cours depuis quatre ans il avait
vous avez appris que le chantier a pris
du retard on parle maintenant de cinq à
sept mois de retard oui donc cinq à sept
mois de retard c'est significatif sans
être catastrophique mais tout de même
concrètement ça veut dire que la prise
de possession du bâtiment qui devait
être faite le 22 avril par le
gouvernement du québec par le ministère
de la santé est repoussé au mois
d'octobre ou novembre 2016
concrètement ça veut dire que les
premiers patients qui pourront arriver
au chu m
ne nous n'arriverons pas donc avant noël
2016 ou janvier 2010 est cependant céder
nos sources sont formelles
malgré ces retards on n'a pas de
craintes quant à la la capacité du
collectif santé montréal a livré à
finaliser justement la construction de
ce super hôpital
on le disait un énorme chantier est ce
que ça pourrait vouloir dire des coûts
supplémentaires pour le gouvernement
selon nos informations parce que le
projet bâti en partenariat public privé
donc le privé assume la fonction
construction ça n'engendrerait pas de
coût supplémentaire pour le gouvernement
et on pense donc la facture resterait
autour de 3 milliards 75 millions de
dollars
l'autre grande question qu'on peut se
poser ce soir c'est de savoir est ce que
ça peut affecter les services aux
patients aux malades justement de la
région de montréal la réponse là tu il
semblerait que ces noms pour une simple
et bonne raison c'est que les trois
entités du ch uem continuerait
simplement pendant cinq à sept mois de
plus à assurer les services à la
population
donc normalement les patients de la
région de montréal ne devraient pas être
affectés par ce retard je vous rappelle
que l'autre super hôpital montréalais
le centre universitaire de santé mcgill
a aussi été livré avec un retard dans ce
cas là on parlait d'un mois de pluie en
2014 très bien merci beaucoup david
bonne soirée